good afternoon of the rules
committee for money for more
levels this year by called
the order of please be advised
and audio and video recording
of today's proceedings be
made as also being televised
automotive sector please call
the roll Cooley here Cunningham
Carillo here date here flora
if Grayson here Kamlager-Dove
yes and quirk Silva
Promesas this year works
here we have a quorum
and we have a consent agenda
is our most on them Senate
gender uber miss Carillo
seconded by Mister deeds
-- matter center
please call the roll probably
-- high Cooley I Carillo
Carillo aye deep deep five
flora -- floor aye Grayson
aye Grayson aye Kamlager-Dove
Kamlager-Dove aye quirk
Silva aye quirk Silva aye
Ramos from most aye Reavis
Reavis I work side by side
very good motions passed
and this rules Cooley
is and I think